DHARSHINI DAVID: Thanks so much.
Thank you, Rob, and thank
you for having me here today.
I'm not quite sure how
I'm going to compete
with next week's program.
Having said that, I've only
spoken at one OTHER Google
event, and that was at
Zeitgeist I said a few years ago
when I was basically chairing
the likes of Stephen Hawking.
David Attenborough was there.
Mo Farah was leading
the morning run.
So I'm not quite sure how to
compete with them, either.
I can't really tell
you about the secrets
behind quantum physics.
I'm not sure I'm going
to be much use in proving
your personal best
of 800 meters,
and I have no idea what lies
beneath the ocean floor.
But instead, I'm going
to try and tell you
in the space of
half an hour or so
a little bit about the
secrets of the global economy.
What are those
economic forces that
shift around all our fortunes?
What lies beneath, and what
lies beneath that global power
base and the way it's changing?
All of that for the price of
a dollar-- a bit of a bargain
there for lunch time.
But "The Almighty Dollar"--
the book I've written--
is about more than
that, in fact.
I was an economist at
the start of my career.
I still am.
But I made the worst economic
decision of my career
some years ago when I decided
to swap a trading floor
for the world of broadcasting.
I thought it would mean pretty
decent money and better hours--
neither of those
two in case anybody
else is thinking of
making a similar move.
But the reason I did it
above everything else
is because I was
frustrated at the way
that economics was
viewed as this--
not just the dismal science,
but the distant science
that people didn't understand.
It didn't matter to them.
It was too complicated.
Why should we try
and explain it?
It was worthy, but
frankly dull, and I'm
afraid that image has continued.
So in that sense, I
feel like I failed.
I feel like the entire
world's media, frankly,
has failed, because this is
what we think about, of course.
When we talk about economics,
we think about big players,
big picture, big numbers.
And I'm sure some
of you here would
have been at Davos
in recent years,
so you could probably recognize
those two photos at the top
there--
[INAUDIBLE] there this year.
What really struck
me as at a time
when we're talking about
the rise of populism,
about dissatisfaction amongst
people around the globe
about their lots in life--
what have we got?
We've got the world's political
leaders and financial leaders
wringing their hands over
the issues of inequality
and stagnant wages and
the rise of the right,
all while sipping their 100
franc glasses of champagne,
dithering about
whether or not to have
a 50 franc croque
monsieur, and retiring
to their 1,000 franc
a night rooms--
none of which is
an exaggeration.
It's not a cheap place to be.
It's the highest town in Europe.
It feels a long way from
many of the day to day issues
that affect people.
But I have a strong feeling
that those forces shouldn't
be viewed in the
abstract like that.
It isn't the case that the
big players actually debate
and determine our forces.
The other image, of
course, we always
talk about when we talk about
the world's financial systems--
markets, that opaque
thing, Wall Street,
the bulls and the
bears, trillions
of dollars changing hands.
Some of the products
even the people
there on the New York
Stock Exchange floor
don't understand what
they're all about.
It's all beyond
our understanding.
It's all beyond our
control, isn't it?
There's more to it, I think.
Because even though
that's the big picture,
I think ultimately what
we need to talk about
is the smallest forces.
And that comes down to,
frankly, the individual dollar.
And it is dollar.
Because even though we've got
all these currencies flowing
around the globe, it's
the dollar that's king.
You call it what you like.
You can call it
the dead president.
You can call it a single.
You can call it a greenback,
but it is the thing.
As much as I studied this,
this is the thing really
that is driving all our forces.
Why the dollar?
Well, it is international
currency of trade,
and we can blame
history for that one.
More on that in a second.
It's also the security
blanket that governments
and central banks cling
to around the world.
It's the world's
reserve currency.
You have that stored away
in case there is a rainy day
as well as in case you need it
for trade and things like that.
And again, there is a reason
why they cling to that dollar.
It's seen as being stable.
It's seen as being the globe's
common financial language.
People will accept a
dollar in a way, of course,
they wouldn't accept
a bitcoin just yet.
And because of that image
of security and stability,
the dollar is also a common way
of holding your debts as well--
loans made between countries,
loans made across borders,
between companies as well.
So a natural fact-- if you look
at the American population,
it's what?
5% of the world total maximum?
But the dollar comes up
in 40% of transactions
around the world.
It's also the currency in which
40% of loans are made as well,
so it's punching way
above its weight.
A bit now about the history of
the dollar, though, because--
well, that's not the
history of the dollar.
That's the world's common
language, isn't it?
And really, it is
the common language
that is driving everything.
But when you look at it,
it's had a little bit
of a checkered past.
And let's just talk a bit
more about that history,
then-- give you a bit
of a glimpse there.
History of a greenback--
from Bohemia to the Bronx.
Well, the dollar-- despite the
name and despite everything
we've heard about it--
isn't, in actual
fact, American at all.
It's no more American
than I was to start with
to be honest, because
what you've got
there is originally what was
known as a "thaler"-- a thaler
coin.
And those were
minted in Bohemia.
That's an original one there.
You can see there 1525, minted
in what was then Bohemia,
now what we'd call
the Czech Republic.
And those silver coins
were used, in actual fact,
across Europe for
hundreds of years.
And if you look back
at popular culture,
they crop up time
and time again.
Shakespeare was quite fond of
actually talking about dollars.
And it comes up--
I think it's the second
scene in "Macbeth."
They talk about $10,000,
which is a little bit
odd, because "Macbeth"--
for those who like theater--
was set in the 11th
century, so dollars
weren't even around back then.
So bit of artistic
license there.
Then, of course, we saw
the dollar being adopted
as the currency in the US.
And again, we have a gentleman
over there, Alexander Hamilton,
to thank-- again storming
Broadway and the West End
right now.
So there's some
kind of connection--
though I'm not quite sure--
between the greenback
and the stage.
But we have him to thank, and
that currency has endured.
So for much that we talk about
the rise of, say, the RMB
or the euro or even
digital currencies,
the dollar somehow has
managed to keep its head
high across all those years.
And in actual fact,
it's continuing.
Having said that, there's been
various bumps in the road.
This was something that none
of us are going to remember,
of course.
This was the Great
Depression, when
we saw the value
of shares dropping
by almost a quarter over the
course of four or five days.
And once investors had
finished dumping their shares,
what do they do next?
They started dumping
their dollars,
exchanging them for gold
because they were so concerned
about the world's
most popular currency
as it was back then, which
meant a great demand for gold.
The American Central
Bank got very worried
about the value of the dollar.
So what does it do to try
and prop up that interest,
keep investors
hanging on to them?
It put up interest rates.
Of course, that's one way
of ensuring that people
want to buy your currency.
They get a better return.
Who pays the price for that?
Well, this is what happens.
You end up with 25%
of your working age
population out of work.
The people who have got jobs
probably are underemployed,
working part-time when they
want to work even longer hours.
So that was the
Great Depression--
GDP output falling by up to
a third over that period,
the economy scarred and damaged.
Having said that,
there was actually
a light at the end of the
tunnel for the dollar.
And this is something-- here
we go back to our dollar again.
And I just want
to show you this.
If you flip over a
dollar, and if you're ever
stuck in an immigration
queue at JFK,
I find it's great
way to pass the time.
There's a symbol
on the back there
which no one quite
knows the meaning of it.
And if you look at it, that is
1935 that went on the dollar.
And many people
looking at are going,
that's a Masonic symbol, right?
In actual fact, when
they looked into it,
the engravers who put
it there weren't masons.
So no one's quite sure what
it means or why it's there.
But if you look at it in
detail, there's the eye of God
up there.
God favors [INAUDIBLE]
the taking.
And at the bottom--
the new world order.
And it was under FDR
that that was put on.
And [INAUDIBLE] psychic.
Nobody quite knows,
but it actually
was a quite an accurate
predictor of the way things
were going to turn out.
Because what happened
after the Second World
War is there was a conference
at a town called Bretton
Woods you've probably
heard of which
was set up to enable
there be lasting peace--
financial stability
around the globe.
What came out of it
was, in many ways,
the main vector of
the Second World War,
and that was the dollar.
It was cemented there as the
international currency of trade
and also that currency
of last resort--
that currency that was
being used primarily
for the bank's reserves.
It was linked to
the value of gold.
It was referred to as
being as good as gold,
and all the other
currencies in turn
had their values
actually linked to that.
That particular
setup didn't last.
But the legacy of all that
was that to this day--
as I was saying a
little bit earlier--
we still do use the dollar as
the currency for doing trade
and also as that
security blanket.
And what does that mean?
Well, ultimately,
whether we like it
or not, whether we're
using dollars every day,
whether we're seeing them,
whether they electronic,
it is touching all
our lives every day.
And through the
choices we make, that
impacts on the economic forces
around the world and the way
that influence and
power shifts as well.
So what I thought
I'd do was have
a look at the dollar and
its journey around the globe
and look at a sort
of series of episodes
of what might happen
if you followed
a dollar around the globe.
What does that tell us
about the powers there?
And it's not an unusual journey.
There's 12 billion dollar notes
in circulation-- almost 12
billion.
And about half of them
are outside of the US--
half of them, which
sounds extraordinary
when you put it that
way, but they are.
So it's not an unusual
journey by any means.
So in terms of looking
at that journey,
let's start in the home
of the big spender.
Let's start in the US where one
in six of every dollars of GDP,
output income, however you
would look at it each year
is generated in the form
of consumer spending.
So it's a nation
of big shoppers.
And even though that's
something that people look upon
as being a negative, it's a
very important thing indeed.
And this particular
transaction--
we're going to look at something
that happens every day.
We're going to look at a
shopper who does what many of us
do-- shopping trip--
end of it-- you just
chuck something in the trolley.
Everyone's been to Ikea.
You know exactly how this works.
You come out spending
more than you
thought with things you think,
I didn't really need that,
but it's in there anyway.
My example-- I looked at a woman
who'd been in a Texan branch--
it doesn't have to be Texas--
of Walmart who puts a
radio into her trolley.
It's cheap.
It's going to give her some
enjoyment in the kitchen
while she's cooking
dinner that night.
But the main thing is,
it's made in China.
And that's something that is
a very important relationship
indeed, because Walmart--
it's all about piling it
high, selling it cheap.
That's the logo it was basically
founded on many years ago.
And to make that
happen, increasingly it
means turning to China
to supply the lines.
You've got tens of
thousands of suppliers
in China just making
stuff for Walmart.
Walmart actually buys more from
China than the whole of Germany
does.
That's how important
that relationship is.
And between them
both, they've come up
with liners that can make the
journey across in five days--
which is, as you can imagine,
a pretty busy route right now.
Of course, the ships
going back the other way
aren't nearly as
full, which adds up
to something quite different.
This has quite a big
impact, of course,
on the American economy.
I lived in New York
about a decade ago,
and this bridge in New Jersey
in Trenton always fascinated me.
It's Trenton Bridge.
And it's lit up to say,
Trenton makes, the world takes.
It's been there for 100 years.
And 100 years ago that was true,
because, of course, what we
saw then was America very
much making what it consumed.
If you bought a
radio back then, it
was likely to have been
built in that factory
up there which is
in Pennsylvania.
That's taken in 1925 just a
couple of hours down the road
from the Trenton bridge.
But that's all
changed since then.
If you're buying a
radio in America,
chances are it's not
made in America at all.
We've now got much cheaper
labor elsewhere, of course.
If you look at the
size of the working age
population in China,
it's five times the size
of that in the US.
So it's no wonder-- for
many other reasons as well--
that labor is a lot
cheaper over there.
You've got cheaper labor.
You've also got
various governments
around the world giving their
industries a helping hand.
What does that add up to?
You've got things like
that like that steel plant
at the bottom lying derelict.
The Rust Belt has turned
very much to dust.
So what is America
actually making?
It's making shoppers.
It's making people who are
buying in goods from abroad,
and that all adds up to a
massive, big trade deficit.
I think it's at $566 billion.
President Trump talked
about $800 billion.
He actually got that wrong.
That's the amount of
goods they buy in.
This is the goods bought in
minus the goods going out.
But what he has actually
touched a nerve with,
obviously, is what this means
to the American economy--
the fact that if
America is not making,
if it's buying from elsewhere,
that does impact on incomes.
It does impact on output.
It impacts in jobs, hence
"make America great again."
It's not everything, though.
There are some things that
America still excels in.
Boeing is saying that over
the next couple of decades,
it expects to get a trillion
dollars worth of orders
from China, which
is extraordinary
when you consider the way
Chinese manufacturing is
evolving.
But that's because America
still excels in the higher tech
areas of manufacturing.
It still has a specialty.
It has a comparative advantage,
but you can't live off
airplanes, of course.
So we've now got this trade
war emerging on the other side
of the Atlantic.
What does that mean?
Well, it means
that Trump puts up
barriers and things
like steel and aluminum,
saying everybody else
is playing unfairly.
This is putting my
manufacturers out of business.
The likes of Europe
retaliate, saying, OK.
We're going to put charge
on things that you still
make like Levi's jeans
and Harley-Davidsons.
No one wins, of course, because
you end up with high prices.
You end up with less business
being done, ultimately.
You end up with less output.
The cost of actually making
those things goes up as well.
So in many ways,
it's the populations
of both who are
loses, and that's
why we've seen trade wars coming
down rather than coming up
in the last few years.
But what does this
mean for China?
Well, of course, if America
is taking, China's making.
It's all happening there
in the Shenzhen factories.
So many of them now--
20,000 suppliers there
grinding out stuff for Walmart.
They're all together.
You got the Pearl River
Delta, which is the biggest
megacity now on the planet.
But what all those
producers have
in common is that they're
not allowed to hang
onto the dollars they make.
Those dollars get funneled up
instead by the financial system
to the central bank, who's got
a very specific use in mind
for them.
And all of that
is down to what's
dictated by the Chinese
government, of course,
in the Great Hall of the People
there on the edge of Tienanmen
Square.
And for many years,
they've said, right.
We're all about producing.
We are going to become
the world's factories
and workshops.
In recent years, the cracks have
started to show in that policy.
Because you've got Vietnam--
wages are now a fifth of
what they are in China.
So the likes of H&M--
they start to look
elsewhere and say,
I'm going to buy my garments
from Vietnam instead.
What does that mean for China?
Well, they also have to
contend with the aftermath
of the financial crisis when
world trade fell by over 15%
in the course of just months.
So they know this
isn't a banker.
They have to think
about diversifying,
so they're trying to create
also a nation of consumers.
So no wonder that
Alibaba has overtaken
Walmart when it comes
to sales and is now
the biggest retailer on Earth.
But back to what
the Chinese people
are doing with the dollar.
This is a really
fascinating one,
because it's got
all these dollars.
What do you do with them?
You can't stick them all under
the mattress by any means.
One of the things, of course--
one of the reasons why China
has hung on so
tightly to dollars
is because it wants to
control its exchange rate.
Why is that?
Well, the cheaper your exchange,
the lower your exchange rate,
the cheaper your exports are,
the more attractive they are.
And that's one of
the reasons why
we have seen all these
trade complaints coming up
in recent years.
Also, of course, it's one
of the reasons why you never
hear the American
government talking
about wanting the dollar to
be stronger, because that's
bad news for producers.
So by keeping
control of the RMB,
it puts the Chinese government
in a very strange position.
Because if you're controlling
your exchange rate,
you're controlling the
amount of your currency
that can flow around
the world, which
means that your
currency's not going
to be able to take on the dollar
when it comes to popularity
of use around the globe.
So you're giving up some
power in that sense.
What it does with
all these dollars,
though-- the
Chinese government's
actually quite conservative
when it comes to investing.
So they like to go out and
buy American government bonds.
That's the form by which the
American government borrows.
It issues these bonds at
quite a low rate of return,
but it's a pretty stable one.
The Chinese
government loves them,
because they know that Uncle
Sam is good for the money.
These are also what's
known as "liquid debt,"
so you can cash them
in quite easily.
They're also what's known
as "deep assets," which
means that if you go
and buy some of them
or sell some of them, there are
so many of them around you're
not going to impact the price.
There is a sense of
stability there as well,
which makes it very popular.
What does that mean for
the American people?
Well, China own
some of its debt.
So in theory you think
that means that China
could hold America to ransom.
In practice, actually,
lots of other countries
want these bonds, too.
So there's always
a buyer for them.
It does mean, however, that
because they're so popular,
the American government can
borrow at very low interest
rate.
And that means that in
turn, American people
can enjoy lower interest rates.
So there's some payback there.
There's also something else
that China uses its dollars for,
and that is to invest abroad--
something that has become
very popular in recent years.
And for China, it
means that dollars
are the key to growing
its economic empire
beyond its shores.
This is the old Silk Road--
which you won't remember unless
you were around in the
times of the Roman Empire--
originally used to bring--
well, this is the new one.
But the old one was meant
to bring silk to Europe
and also brought things
like carrots the other way.
Now the Chinese government
is investing billions--
trillions even--
in building a new maritime
and also the road--
Silk Road-- to try and
increase its trade passages
and also increase its
influence as well.
All of this-- and you
add in all the companies
and the mergers and
acquisitions going on as well.
For the first time
in 2014, China
invested more money abroad than
was being invested in China.
It's an interesting
switch of position there.
Why?
Because China is thinking about
how it grows its influence
around the globe.
And it's not just those routes
you can see there on the map.
Because if you're
investing in dollar
as the Chinese government,
you might send it
somewhere like Nigeria, which
is what I looked at next.
Why Nigeria?
Well, this is a very,
very strange one indeed--
because they're
building railroads.
Why would you build a railroad
in Nigeria-- $12 billion
worth of railroad?
It goes from Calabar, which
is a port town, to Lagos,
the financial capital.
It crosses some oil fields,
and that's the clue.
China needs oil to develop.
Nigeria has it.
China wants to have influence
over these oil fields.
It might want to get
some of those contracts.
What better way than being a
friend of Nigeria's, exerting
some soft power--
that kind of economic diplomacy?
Building a railroad
there enables
people to get around
as well and for cargo
to get around in a country
where road journeys are
quite perilous and railroads are
currently very underdeveloped.
Great news for
Nigeria, isn't it?
They get railroads.
They get infrastructure.
China get some jobs as
well for its workers.
Nigeria get some jobs as well.
But there's a
downside, of course,
because by ceding
some of your territory
there, by accepting China's
dollars, you're in actual fact,
saying, well, we're giving
up some power as well.
So that's one reason why
when we talk about the oil
wealth in Nigeria--
very, very little of it actually
passes into local hands.
Because it's foreign
companies, foreign money that's
coming in and actually
paying into those things
and reaping the gains
at the same time.
And it's more than that as well.
That's the market in Lagos.
Now, you can see there some
of the local cloth there being
sold-- a huge source of
income there, very popular.
But now you tend to find--
it's about $1 a yard,
I think, on average.
But the Chinese imports
are undercutting that
substantially, so
what you're seeing
is local traders there
being put out of business.
And what we've seen in
the last few years--
it's investment there
overcoming the level of aid
given to Nigeria,
which has thrown up
lots of questions about what
is the answer when you've
got-- as Nigeria has.
Nigeria had huge problems with
a famine not that long ago
partly because of
conflict in the country.
What do you do in a
situation like that?
Is it all about investment?
Is it about aid?
Well, both come with
strings attached
seems to be the answer.
Even aid nowadays--
there's all sorts
of concerns about the
right types of projects,
the right kind of
appropriation funds as well.
So it's one of those
debates that keeps going on.
And if you want to develop--
do you want infrastructure like
Nigeria's getting off China?
If you get it from
China, there's
going to be strings attached.
If you get it through aid as
well-- is that the answer?
But the other thing
that, of course--
Nigeria also has to
import a lot of food.
Because one of the problems
about being an economy that
has been subject to so much
conflict as it has been
is that, in actual fact, your
national dish-- if it's rice
and you can't grow enough, it's
got to come from elsewhere.
So I followed that
dollar to India next
to see exactly what would
happen if you then had
to buy your rice from India.
And that's quite a popular
route in actual fact,
because even though we think
about individual countries
producing commodities, that
money goes through a middleman.
It goes through four or five
major commodities traders,
and they trade in dollars,
which is why we're still talking
about dollars right now.
So that brings us to India.
And India is a really
interesting example here
of how you look at
growth and prosperity,
because you've got the
rice bowl there of India--
over 165 million
tons of rice produced
by India last year, second
only to China in that regard.
But on the other
hand, you've got
2/3 of the population
of working age in India
employed in agriculture.
Most of them still
live in poverty.
They're only about
10% as productive
as their American
counterparts, and that's
for a number of reasons.
You've got things like tiny
farms, poor land rights,
poor use of machinery,
low levels of technology.
And then on top of that,
your infrastructure's
so bad that even if you manage
to produce that kilo of rice,
up to half of it
might have gone off
by the time it gets to the
ports it was destined for.
And then there's the
middle man as well.
There's those big
commodities traders.
So the average Indian
is not seeing very much
of the value of what they're
trying to produce there--
and then that strange
situation where
the country can't feed
itself, and also many farmers
can't make a living.
That's one side of
the Indian economy.
We know it's the fastest
growing major economy right now.
Why?
What do I need to tell you,
actually, in this room?
You probably know
the answer already.
It's all to do with
tech and the fact
that 25 years ago we were
looking at a tech industry that
was worth about $2 billion-- now
well in excess of $100 billion,
of course.
I won't go into
any more of that,
because you know all
about how successful that
has been in terms of
propelling the tech
industry around the globe.
But it means that India has
taken a very strange route
to get there, because most
countries undergo an Industrial
Revolution.
India didn't.
India kind of just jumped ahead.
It went, I'm not doing
an Industrial Revolution.
I'm not exporting-- like China
did-- manufactured goods.
I'm going to go
straight to tech.
Does it need to
have the middle man?
Probably, yes.
If you look at what's
going on in India,
you've got 65 million
people living in slums--
people moving out from
rural areas saying,
I can't afford to live here.
I'm moving to the cities,
but there's nothing for them.
So the government's trying
to get a handle on that
by saying, well, we need to
think more about investing.
They're trying to attract
foreign money-- which
is quite a departure for
the Indian government--
and also trying to
involve more technology.
They also tried this strange
experiment of doing away
with 500,000 rupee notes--
demonetization-- partly to
weed out the informal economy,
tax evaders, dodgy activities.
India is an unusually
cash-based economy.
It didn't quite work,
because the people who
were professional enough
to be dodging taxes
and the big timers were
actually able to put their money
in some others things as well.
Gold jewelers were
working through the night.
The people who really suffered
in that kind of experiment were
housewives-- the people who had
money hidden under the bed--
because they couldn't explain
where it came from, so
they couldn't exchange
it for the new notes.
So it didn't quite work there.
But on the other hand,
one of the things
that did happen, as you can see,
are greater growth of things
like--
well, digital banking
took off in a big way.
And also you get things
like [INAUDIBLE] drivers
who now accept digital
payments as well,
so it did have some impact.
But really, the government--
when it's trying to modernize--
has to look at more
traditional routes.
It has to look at
things like investing.
It also has to look
at building roads.
As I mentioned there,
an awful lot of produce
gets wasted simply
because India doesn't
have the roads to connect
its 650,000 villages.
But it wants to change
that, so the government's
got a very ambitious
road building project.
Depending on which estimate
they want to on which day,
it's either 20
kilometers or 25 miles.
There's quite a big
difference between the two.
We'll just accept that they're
trying to build more roads.
But to build roads,
you need oil,
because oil is what
does into road surfaces
as well as into the cars and
trucks that drive on them.
Where are you going to get
that oil from if you're India?
How about Iraq?
So let's follow that
dollar on to Iraq.
And that is the
Missan oil fields.
That's near Basra, and they
produce a very particular type
of oil.
Because even though we
talk about crude oil,
there's different grades of oil.
The stuff that goes into cars
is typically light, sweet oil.
Don't drink it.
It's just called that
because of the way it flows
and because of the
way it evaporates
as well if you spill.
The stuff you use in roads
is the heavier grades--
the sour grades.
It tends to be a
bit cheaper as well.
And the oil filled
in Basra-- they
realized that they
can actually get away
with splitting this
into the course stuff
and selling that
on at a discount.
And India is quite
literally lapping that up.
So you've got a
ready customer there.
It's not just India.
If you look across
the world, on average,
each man, woman, and
child uses the equivalent
of over two liters
of crude oil per day
if you look at consumption
across the globe.
That's going particularly
fast, of course,
in countries like
China and India.
So there is a
steady demand there.
You would think that
equals power, right?
Not necessarily.
Having oil doesn't always
mean you have more power.
Where there's oil,
there is dollars,
and there's a very
specific reason for that.
In the 1970s, Saudi
Arabia and the US
did a deal whereby the US said,
well, you can use our dollars.
And in return you'll
have the protection
of our foreign policy.
You have our backing.
And Saudi went,
thanks very much.
That's great.
And in return, we'll make sure
we have a special relationship
with you, your big
gas guzzlers, and I'm
sure we can make this work.
And it has worked ever since.
But what Saudi has
found-- and of course,
last week we saw a great
delegation visiting 10
Downing Street
almost cap in hand,
because Saudi has
discovered that having oil
doesn't necessarily
equal riches forever.
Even if demand is
going up, the price
can fluctuate from year
to year quite a bit.
And those prices are
determined on global markets.
And even though Saudi
Arabia and other countries
have got together
to form OPEC and try
to influence that price,
they don't have much impact.
And it's got so bad
now that Saudi Arabia,
like many other
countries, can no longer
balance its books based on
the oil revenue it's getting.
It's trying to diversify.
Many countries
find that actually
having natural resources
like that can be what's
called the paradox of plenty.
You think you've
got this rich seam,
but it can open up your economy
to all sorts of vulnerability.
There is the
fluctuation in price.
There's this thing
called "Dutch disease."
When they found oil
in the North Sea,
the Netherlands thought, great.
This is it.
Our fortunes are made.
In actual fact, because the
demand for their currency
was so great, the
exchange rate shot up.
Other industries couldn't cope
with that, and what we saw
was unemployment
rising at a time
when it was selling a lot
of oil and the economy
being in trouble.
Also, if you're in
Nigeria or indeed, Iraq,
you'd know full well
that where there's oil,
there tends to be conflict.
For IS, of course,
grabbing oil fields in Iraq
was a major source of
income for many years.
And that means that the Iraqi
government-- although it's
got many things, it
probably feels it could
be doing without oil income.
It's very reliant
on oil income--
instead has to use part of it to
actually defend its oil fields.
So what do you do with that?
Well, we're going to go
over a well-worn path now,
because we're heading
off to Russia.
A lot of arms that
you'll find-- and this
is true when IS ripped
open bombs dating back
to the times of Saddam Hussein
and stole weapons in Iraq.
Many of them had basically made
in Russia or the equivalent
printed on the side.
And there's a reason
for this as well--
the Cold War.
And Russia, of
course, was obsessed
with churning out weaponry
to show that it could compete
with America-- so
much so that it
neglected almost all other
forms of manufacturing.
It was all about creating
the means of destruction.
It was all very much along
Soviet planning lines.
You had quotas for how much you
produced, how it was produced.
Fathers followed.
Their sons followed on.
The factory dictated your every
way of life-- your housing,
what was in your houses.
Those times are now
gone, but Russia then
found that this was still
its area of expertise.
It's still very much
at the forefront.
It's second only to America.
And the way they sell as well--
they sell to their
friends, so America
supplies the rest of NATO-- for
example, Saudi Arabia, Russia,
a lot of the developing world.
But again, Russia's
going to have
to think about how that
changes over the coming years,
because China is saying, we
can make this stuff cheaper.
And also, Russian soldiers
find themselves quite often
staring down the
barrel of guns that
were designed in their country.
Weapons fall into
the wrong hands.
Now, that's before you
consider all the ethics
of the dark side of creating the
means of destruction as well.
There's two things that Russia
is dependent on for the money
it gets-- its
weapons and also oil.
Its economy overall has
been pretty unstable,
and that goes all the way back
to the times of the Cold War
and before.
So while Russia was
churning out arms
to protect its
border, in its cities,
America's currency
during the Cold War
was actually having a heyday.
Everyone from hotels to
prostitutes in Moscow
were accepting dollars.
Why?
Because you could use those to
spend in hard currency stores
which had stocks where
there were times when
shelves were empty elsewhere.
And we may think of Russia
pulling the strings today
in terms of fixing
elections or fake news
or however you
want to look at it,
but America still holds
an economic power.
And that's still
true for this day.
Why?
Because it was all about trust.
People don't trust the ruble,
and money is about trust.
You've got to trust
its value-- that it's
going to keep that
value, it's going
to be an acceptable
means of exchange,
and it's something you
can use to repay debt.
The dollar fit the
bill a lot better
than the ruble
throughout the Cold War
and indeed since as well.
A lot of the oligarchs-- if they
want to keep their money safe--
hold onto it in dollars.
But the dollar comes with
some strange powers attached.
The cartoon there--
that was in a newspaper
just after the raids on
FIFA's headquarters in Geneva
which was all orchestrated
by the Americans.
Why did the Americans care?
They don't even
care about football.
They call it soccer.
They did care, because the whole
bribery scandal had touched
the American financial system.
It had touched the dollar.
And anything that does
that means that America
has jurisdiction to go
out there and take action,
and that's exactly
what they did.
Another way that
America has tried
to wield economic power--
along with Europe, of course--
is sanctions after
Russia's actions in Ukraine
a few years ago.
And that has driven the Russian
economy further to its knees
into recession and, of
course, also created
a bit of a crisis in
confidence in the ruble.
And that, too, has been
good for the dollar.
A lot of people who aren't
actually affected by sanctions
try and keep their
money in dollars,
and that's quite
often elsewhere.
And if you're one of
these individuals who
has been affected by sanctions,
where might you put your money?
How about Germany?
Why Germany?
Because partly of the
friendship between these two.
And they didn't always
look so friendly.
Apparently at their
first meeting,
Putin brought along
his black Labrador.
Sounds like a
friendly thing to do,
but Angela Merkel
has a lifelong fear
of dogs after being bitten.
So some saw that as her
being terrorized by him.
But since then,
they seem to have
grown a warmer and
cozier relationship,
and that's a good
reason for that.
40% of gas supplied to
Germany comes from Russia.
So effectively, Russia
is keeping the lights
on in Germany over the winter.
So Germany therefore has
been a little bit more
reticent about applying
sanctions on Russia.
They've also been a little
more welcoming to money
coming in from Russia, and
Germany has a long history
of thriving on investment.
The Marshall Plan was the
money that was-- again,
it was the US
Treasury Secretary who
donated some dollars equivalent
of $140 billion in 2017 money
after the Second World
War to rebuilding Germany.
It sounds very altruistic.
But it also came about because
America was concerned otherwise
Germany would fall into
the hands of communists,
and therefore they'd be
facing another opponent.
It also meant a ready
market for their goods.
That was the idea--
instead of which
Germany grew into a massive
industrial superpower
and also created the
financial system that you need
to enable that kind of growth.
Russia has a lot of money
in Germany today as well.
That there is a
refinery invested
in by the Russian
energy supplies.
In actual fact, Russian
energy suppliers
account for about half
of Russian money going
into Germany today.
But it also means that it's an
attractive place, for example,
for an arms dealer who's got
a dollar that you want to use
for your retirement plan.
What could you do?
You could buy property
in Berlin,m for example.
And that's the kind of example
I looked at in the book.
All that money
plowing into Germany
means it's, of course, the
biggest economy in Europe now.
It's been the architect
of the single market
and also the kingpin
behind the euro.
Let's take a couple of minutes
to talk about the euro,
because the euro is
an interesting one.
American bankers
were really scared
about the creation of the euro.
They thought it would take over
from the dollar as the world's
leading currency-- the
most eminent currency.
Hasn't quite happened.
The euro's still there in
Central Bank's reserves.
It's still seen as a
source of stability.
But some say it with
a sense of suspicion,
partly because of the
way the euro came about.
And that was because there
was various entry criteria.
All the countries joining it
had to be basically driving
at the same speed in
the same direction.
They fudged some of the rules
for that one for Germany
as much as for Greece,
so what you ended up with
was economies who very
quickly became quite clear
that one interest
rate wasn't going
to suit all their interests.
That's quite different,
of course, to America
where you've got one currency,
one interest rate, and one
political system as well.
And those cracks
became even clearer
during the time of
the financial crisis
when it became quite clear
that Greece, for example,
was in all sorts of problems.
And Germany wasn't that
keen on bailing out Greece.
They were very
different economies.
And because of
that, the questions
still being asked about
the future of the euro.
And that is throwing its whole
credibility into question,
and it carries on.
The UK, of course, decided
after several tests
not to join the euro.
It looked at everything.
It even looked at how
much Mars Bars costed
in each European country to
try and compare how convergent
they were with each other.
But it decided not to.
And at the time, many thought
that was a huge mistake
and that what we'd find instead
was that Germany would be
the [INAUDIBLE] on the outside.
In fact, it became the world's
largest financial center.
Is that going to continue?
Well, who knows.
Of course, the dollar
lies beneath a lot
of the financial crisis.
But the UK being the financial
center of what we saw
was the crisis
starting in America--
homeowners who
couldn't repay loans,
banks who had repackaged
those loans into investment
products they didn't really
understand-- those collapsed.
Financial system over
here feels the wobbles.
You get queues outside the
banks like Northern Rock.
And then we get
quantitative easing.
We get all that money
pumped in effectively
meant to create loans to be
doled out by institutions.
Did that work?
Well, the global economy
is back on its feet
again, so it seems
to have worked.
On the other hand, when
you look at the evidence,
only a small part
of that money seems
to have been filtering
through into consumption.
Most of it seems to have
just bumped up asset prices
once again.
Debt levels are now a point now
when people are worrying again
about the possibility of
another financial crisis.
But one thing that
worries people
is whether or not we can
remain the financial capital.
We've still got
the dollars flowing
in-- partly a consequence
of location, language,
and, as we all know,
London's the best place
in the world to live.
But the way the
conversations are going now
between the government
and the European Council--
that might be something
that's under jeopardy.
And of course, so
many businesses
now are looking elsewhere
for trade deals.
So I talk about the dollar
going back home, because you've
got a business person
there picking up
a dollar at the foreign exchange
bureau to go back to Houston
and over in Houston pays it over
to the concierge of his hotel
who happens to be the woman
we see at the beginning buying
her radio.
And that throws up questions
about whether America
can be made great again.
And it also touches
on this disease--
this very real disease--
which is the
productivity puzzle.
It's affecting the whole
of the Western world
at the moment which
is that, per hour,
we've not really seen
output increasing
at any great speed since
the financial crisis.
Why is that?
We've had a lack of
investment, nerves, of course.
There's also
technology and the fact
that we may not be measuring
these things properly.
Whatever is going on there,
until we sort out that puzzle,
we're not going to be able
to compete with the emerging
globe.
So looking at all these
journeys around the world,
one thing becomes clear.
It's the dollar that's keeping
globalization in business.
And it's not the
big dollars, it's
the small dollars which add
up to a very big sum indeed.
It's all those
individual decisions
people are taking
around the globe--
what kind of goods to buy,
where to buy their oil from,
where to invest their money.
And that's how those
economic ties are turning.
And as those tides turn, it's
creating a global shift as well
in power bases.
What's keeping the
wheels turning?
It's not so much real
money, it's imaginary money.
It's all that debt
we've created.
And we've learned
a lot of lessons
since the financial crisis,
through central banks
don't want to know about it.
Many of us don't know about it.
It keeps our finances
going, but it's debt.
That's the big
elephant in the room.
What does the future look like?
Well, we could see the RMB--
if the Chinese government
changed their attitude a bit--
coming up the stakes.
We could see the euro perhaps
looking a little bit more
solid.
Digital currencies
might mean the future,
although at the moment
I think it's a bubble.
But at the moment,
it's the dollar
that still reigns supreme.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Well, we have about
10 minutes for questions.
We'll go with the hard half one
finish if you have meetings.
I will kick off with a question.
What is your
opinion on big tech?
So if you think that
Amazon, for example,
is taking a huge amount
of consumer dollars,
what's your opinion on
that and perhaps where
that might lead
us in the future?
And if you have a question,
please put your hand up.
DHARSHINI DAVID: As in
whether it's a force for good?
SPEAKER: Yes, and perhaps
comparable to nation states,
for example, if you think
how much Amazon has compared
with smaller GDP countries.
DHARSHINI DAVID: Sure.
It's a bit like the
dollar, isn't it?
It has traversed nation states.
Is it a force for good?
Basically what it does
is epitomizes the way
our global economy
is changing, and it
epitomizes all these
forces of globalization.
We're all using consumer power
to get the American dream
on the cheap, and
we all want that.
What are you sacrificing?
You're sacrificing
perhaps the things
that we've come to hold
dear-- things like employment
practices and things like that.
So I think if you're looking
at Amazon in particular,
there's pros and cons.
It's a bit like making
America great again, isn't it?
You can buy cheap,
but there is a price.
AUDIENCE: I wanted
to ask a question
about the choice of telling
a story about the dollar,
because I imagine as
an economist you'd
have used lots of
mathematical models
to describe these phenomena.
And I was just interested that
you've gone with this narrative
approach and whether you've
tried communicating with models
and failed.
DHARSHINI DAVID: So if
I've tried communicating--
AUDIENCE: Those kinds of models
through journalism or whatever,
and maybe it doesn't work?
DHARSHINI DAVID: Yes.
It doesn't work.
People distrust models,
because they don't understand.
We've heard recently
the news, of course,
this thing about
economic forecasters
have no idea what
they're talking about.
I used to be an economic
forecaster, and yeah.
There are models, and
they're very good models.
The treasury, for
example, in the UK
employs hundreds of people.
They're programming and
coming up with these things
and testing them and
constant;y changing them,
as does the Bank of England.
But I also know-- having been an
economist and worked with these
models--
that what you get out
depends on what you put in.
So you can make
various assumptions,
and that will impact
on what you get out.
So I'm a little bit cautious
sometimes about extolling
the virtues of models too much.
AUDIENCE: You painted
a very lucid picture
about how complicated
the global system is.
But obviously, 2008, 2007
showed that economists
don't have all the answers.
Do you still trust economists--
macroeconomists specifically--
and a little bit
more information
around those models?
And are we perhaps
measuring the right thing?
I can't remember off
the top of my head--
there was a conversation
recently about GDP
not measuring a certain aspect
of the productive economy
and incorporating
new things into it.
I guess just your
thoughts around that
would be interesting.
DHARSHINI DAVID: Do
I trust economists?
Good question.
I think it's a bit like being
an astrologer or a weather
forecaster, isn't it
to a certain point?
You get a lot of bad press
when you get it wrong,
and it's easy to get it wrong.
And there's all those jokes
about economists in a room,
and you get more views
than there are economists.
I think in terms of
analyzing the facts--
And I think an
economist's job should
be to pull apart the facts,
see the underlying picture.
What we found in recent
years in particular
is that politics
personalities tend
to obscure those facts
and the underlying trends.
I think economists
could do a better
job in bringing those to light.
When it comes to
protecting things,
I think we got a little bit
too complacent about looking
at the past.
And a lot of economists
who were working
around the time the financial
crisis quite honestly
had never seen a
proper recession.
You'd have to go
back to the '70s
to see a really
sharp economic shock.
They just weren't used to it,
and the models had kind of
got a bit complacent too.
And you mentioned the GDP.
This is a really
interesting point
about whether we measure
the world's well being
in forms of the amount of
income we can generate,
and there's much
more to the picture.
That measurement of
income doesn't take
account of a lot of things.
It doesn't take
account of the fact
that you might go home
after a 12-hour day,
and you've still got a whole
lot of DIY to do or housework
or whatever.
None of that counts.
There's a famous example of
if you marry your cleaner,
you're reducing GDP.
Because before that,
the cleaner's output
classed as part of GDP.
Marry the cleaner and it's just
counted as domestic work, which
doesn't show up.
Also, GDP doesn't measure things
like environmental impact.
Technological change-- which
is one of the things that was
written about recently--
is the fact that when
you look at GDP measures,
they haven't taken
account the way
that technology's
moved in recent years.
And therefore, in
many ways, we're
underestimating the health
of the global economy.
So there's a lot more
work to be done on that.
And I think it's
something that now
we've got past the seismic
shocks of the financial crisis,
central banks are finally
waking up and paying attention.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
When you give out a loan, you
have some kind of expectation
that you get the money back.
But given that countries
have such a big debt--
in particular, the US--
why does it not all collapse?
Is it feasible that you
can get the money back?
DHARSHINI DAVID: I
don't know if it's
feasible you can
get the money back.
America's counting the
fact that everyone wants--
America in particular
is counting on the fact
that everyone wants dollars
to trade and to keep
in bank reserves, and that's
why it can sell those bonds.
That's why it can
fund its deficits
and ultimately its debts.
It means that America is seen
as being good for the money.
If China and Japan got together
and said, what do you think.
Should we ask for
our money back?
That could undermine
the economy.
It's one reason why the
yen has never taken off
in a big way as a
major reserve currency,
because investors
around the globe
have been so concerned about
the state of the amount of debt
Japan has that they don't see
as being a stable and therefore
ultimately attractive economy.
But because the dollar has a
special status because it's
required for other
things, America
doesn't suffer that problem.
SPEAKER: I'll go with one
more, and then we'll round off.
What do you think--
so outside of Brexit, what's
perhaps the next big thing
coming down the line that we
should be aware of that perhaps
people aren't?
Is it aging population?
Is it unforeseen tech--
AI [INAUDIBLE]?
What's front of your mind that
we should be thinking about?
DHARSHINI DAVID: Yeah.
I had something up there
about aging population
which I didn't talk
about because I
was conscious of time.
As we're talking right
here, Philip Hammond
is on his feet talking about
the state of public finances
here in the UK.
He's talking about the
next couple of years.
But to me, the big problem
that's looming for all of us
is the fact that
populations are aging.
And that puts a whole
different kind of emphasis
on the finances we have-- public
finances and private finances
and the way we live,
the way we work,
and the way we fund everything.
I don't think any
government has really
thought that one through.
And every time they try to,
they stick a toe in the water.
Things like dementia
tax, of course--
hugely controversial.
But there is a valid
issue hiding under all
that-- that somehow we're
going to think of the fact
that the average person
who's over 64 costs
four times as much
in health care
as someone under the age of 16.
And someone's going to
have to pay that bill.
We're going to live longer.
We're going to live better
and longer hopefully,
but how do we pay for that?
And I think that's
something that
has to be the subject
of much debate.
And hopefully them at Davos
might get their heads around it
as well.
SPEAKER: With that,
please join me
in a massive round of
applause for Dharshini.
[APPLAUSE]